we're asked to find the conjugate of the
complex number 7 minus 5i and what
you're going to find in this video is
finding the conjugate of a complex
number is shockingly easy it's really
the same as this number i should say be
a little bit more particular it has the
same real part so the conjugate of this
is going to have the exact same real
part but its imaginary part is going to
have the opposite sign so instead of
having a negative 5i it will have a
positive
a positive 5i so that right there is the
complex conjugate of 7 minus 5i and
sometimes the notation for doing that is
you'll take 7 minus 5i
if you have 7 minus 5i
7 minus 5i and you put a line over it
like that that means i want the
conjugate of 7 minus 5i and that will
equal 7 plus 5i or sometimes someone
will write you'll see z is the variable
that people often use for complex
numbers if z is 7 minus 5i if z is 7
minus 5i then they'll say the complex
conjugate of z and you put that line
over the z is going to be 7 plus 5i now
you're probably saying okay fairly
straightforward to find a conjugate of a
complex number but what is it good for
and the simplest reason or the most
basic place where this is useful is when
you multiply any imaginary any complex
number times its conjugate you're going
to get a real number and i want to
emphasize this this right here is the
conjugate 7 plus 5i is the conjugate of
7 minus 5i but 7 minus 5i is also the
conjugate of 7 plus 5i for obvious
reasons if you started with this and you
changed the sign of the imaginary part
you would get 7 minus 5i they're
conjugates of each other but let me show
you that when i multiply complex
conjugates that i get a real number so
let's multiply 7 minus 5i times 7 plus
5i and i will do that in blue
7 minus 5i
times 7 plus 5i and remember whenever
you multiply these expressions you
really just have to multiply every term
times each other you could do the
distributive property twice you could do
something like foil to remind yourself
to multiply every every part of this
complex number times every part of this
complex number so let's just let's just
do it any which way so you'd have 7
times 7 which is 49
7 times 5i which is
7 times 5i which is 35i
then you have negative 5i times 7 which
is negative 35i you can see the
imaginary part is cancelling out then
you have negative 5i times positive 5i
well that's negative 25i squared and
negative 25i squared remember i squared
is negative 1. so negative 25 i squared
let me write this down negative 5 i
times 5i
is negative 25 times i squared i squared
is negative 1. so negative 25 times
negative 1 is positive 25. and these two
guys over here cancel out and we're just
left with 49 plus 25 see 50 plus 25 is
75 so this is just 74.
so we are just left with the real number
74. another way to do it you don't even
have to do all this distributive
property you might just recognize that
this looks like this is this is
something plus something time or
something minus something times that
same something plus something and we
know this pattern from our early algebra
that a plus b a plus b times a minus b
is equal to a squared minus b squared is
equal to a difference of squares and so
in this case a is 7 a squared is 49 and
b
b in this case is 5 i
b squared is 5 i squared which is 25 i
squared which is negative 25 and we're
subtracting that so it's going to be
positive plus 25 you add them together
you get 74.